America may be under attack by China in
this way China is the target of economic
espionage investigations in nearly all
56 FBI field offices we met up with FBI
director Christopher ray at the agency's
headquarters in Washington yesterday he
told us in an exclusive interview how
China is looking to steal secrets on
everything from American technology to
agriculture if I look at our
counterintelligence mission overall
China is our top priority in that space
we've had cases involving everything
from turbine technology in places like
upstate New York to corn seed
development in Iowa what do you mean
corn see they're trying to steal our
corn seed well of course we have I think
America's agriculture is the envy of the
world
and we're very proud of it and we should
be and whenever we're the best at
something somebody else is chasing us
it's something that I think most
Americans don't understand what are they
trying to steal what do they want
they're trying to steal our trade
secrets our ideas our innovation the US
Trade Representative put a figure on the
theft of intellectual property and it's
up to six hundred billion dollars
annually it's enormous
the thing that people need to understand
is that this has an impact on everyday
people it has an impact on American
businesses it has an impact on American
jobs it has an impact on American
consumers how so well China's goal is to
take what it can and become essentially
self-sufficient and put American
businesses out of business well to
replace America as the world's economic
superpower I think that's their goal and
they're pretty open about it it's not
only these individuals who are engaged
in spying its companies you've raised
concerns about the Chinese telecom
Giants Huawei and ZTE why are they
national security risks well any time
you start talking about foreign
companies that are holding two foreign
governments that don't share our values
and our dedication to the rule of law
enables them to conduct economic
espionage
Abel's them to conduct different kinds
of cyberattacks
it enables them to steal information in
a variety of ways the president
intervened a few months ago to save ZTE
from some of these crippling financial
penalties that Congress wanted was the
president wrong I continue to be very
concerned and I think the intelligence
community continues to be very concerned
about the threat to our
telecommunications infrastructure
presented by some of the kinds of
companies that are beholden to foreign
governments that don't share our values
and the idea of letting the Fox in the
henhouse is something that I think
people need to be really really careful
about before we find out that we're
going to regret it
directory I know you have been asked
this many times but I do want to ask it
of you because the president has issued
repeated attacks on the FBI on the
integrity of its work on the people who
work here at the FBI in fact he said
that the reputation of the FBI is in
tatters those attacks I have to have
taken their toll I'll tell you what I
see I see 37,000 men and women who get
up every day trying to keep 325 million
American people safe I see people who
work their tails off in that effort who
are people of character of courage of
professionalism and diligence and we do
thousands and thousands of
investigations every year I think about
the agents that I swear in at Quantico
several times a year who compete like
heck to be accepted into the ranks of
the FBI I could give you example after
example that's the FBI that I see that's
the real FBI and that's what we're about
how would you describe your relationship
with President Trump my focus is on
having a very professional relationship
with the president I think that's what
I've been trying to do since day one and
that's true today just as much as it was
on day one he tweets a lot about cabinet
members and top members of his
administration but you specifically have
never been the subject of one of his
tweets
well I'm not much of a Twitter guy as
people will tell you and that's not
meant to criticize Twitter at social
media commentary has its place I just
find that I've got enough to do all day
long running the FBI that without
getting too hung up and worrying about
what's on Twitter the FBI director has a
motto keep calm and tackle hard hmm and
I think that's the message he's trying
to send not only through the 37,000
strong FBI that is keeping us safe every
single day is fighting back there you
heard about China which is stealing 600
billion dollars from us trying to make
sure our elections are safe kidnapped
kids they go after and help rescue our
kids I mean I think that we need to
realize just how much the FBI does for
the average everyday American right and
also the Fox in that house that was
really interesting to let it was great
to hear from them Nora yeah